i want to talk about how to
balance your hormones or manipulate your
hormones in a positive way so the first
question is what is a hormone
hormones are communication
particles that travel through the body
from one place to another they originate
from a gland that makes them and then
they travel through the bloodstream
and then they get received by a receptor
so right now i'm talking to you and
hopefully you're listening to me through
your receptors to the ears you can see
me through the receptors of your
eyeballs but without me seeing you in
person i don't really know if
these words are connecting to you and in
the body when the communication is
received there's another signal sent
back
as a feedback loop it's like a little
circuit type thing like a thermostat in
your house as soon as it hits a certain
temperature
maybe the heater turns off in the body
as soon as a certain blood pressure is
achieved
certain hormones will turn off maybe the
hormone regulating sodium and fluid as
soon as a certain blood sugar is
achieved like 80 certain hormones are
then turned off so if there's no
feedback mechanism with hormones then
the hormone starts going higher and
higher and higher and higher and that
would be really bad in the body but
that's the problem in the body with
hormones you somehow disrupt this
feedback mechanism whether you block the
receptors through what's called
endocrine disruptors that would be like
the pesticides insecticides herbicides
fungicides
that can block the receptors and now
there's no mechanism for this your
hormones to turn off they start going
higher and higher and higher and just as
a side note all those things i just
mentioned the pesticides insecticides
herbicides fungicides actually mimic
estrogen in the body
so an endocrine disruptor is really an
estrogen disruptor and then you have
another situation that doesn't
necessarily block a receptor but it can
actually cause the receptor not to work
anymore or the receptor starts resisting
the hormone that's called hormone
resistance and that happens
in quite a few hormones including
estrogen
and even cortisol where you have this
high level of chronic output of estrogen
for example and then the cells start
blocking that and now
that hormone doesn't work anymore so let
me just give you like a very rare
example this really probably never
happens in life
let's say you start eating a lot of
carbohydrates right for many many years
and you're eating all these
carbohydrates and you're raising insulin
and eventually you develop what's called
insulin resistance and now that receptor
doesn't work anymore so the body makes
more and more and more and then
eventually that communication starts
going down down down and then now the
blood sugars get out of control and you
become a diabetic so that's another
problem with hormones same thing happens
with cortisol resistance where you have
too much chronic stress over a period of
time and then the function of cortisol
which is normally an anti-inflammatory
it doesn't work and you end up with
inflammation and pain so
there's really three dominating
hormones that tend to nullify and
destroy everything else one would be the
insulin
next one would be cortisol from the
stress and then the last one is estrogen
okay those three
tend to be dominating and they tend to
inhibit all these other hormones so let
me just kind of go through the hormones
and talk about what you can eat
to
provide
more balance with individual specific
hormones all right let's start with the
thyroid
thyroid t4
is the thyroid hormone and 4 represents
the number of iodine molecules in that
hormone so to help enhance t4 you need
to consume more iodine so that comes
from
c kelp it comes from seafood
anything from the c now what about if
you wanted to convert
t4 to the t3 which is the active form of
the thyroid hormone so there's a another
nutrient that helps you convert those
two because it's really not about how
much t4 you have it's about
how active
that thyroid hormone becomes in the
conversion to t3 now
80 percent of the conversion happens in
the liver and 20 happens in the kidneys
and so you need a healthy liver and
kidneys to have this work but selenium
is the key mineral for this conversion
and so the best food for selenium is a
brazil nut just one a day will give you
all the selenium you need and by the way
selenium is also in this seafood it's in
the sea kelp now if you have too much
thyroid hormone okay some people have a
hyperthyroid condition uh one way to
inhibit that would be to consume
cruciferous vegetables because there's a
certain compound in cruciferous
vegetables that can inhibit iodine all
right next hormone is cortisol
and
of course
lowering stress will help you with
cortisol but as far as foods go you
would want to eat food that's high in
both potassium and magnesium these are
the two minerals
that help counter cortisol and help
relax the body and so more salad more
leafy greens would be what you want to
do also if you have a
low cortisol situation
sea salt is good to take too because
when the adrenal glands burn out you
also lose the retention of sodium and so
if you're not consuming enough sea salt
that can weaken the adrenals all right
next hormone is growth hormone this is
the anti-aging hormone this is the
hormone that
helps you preserve your muscles and
other proteins to stimulate this hormone
you need to
make sure that you
keep your stress low you want to make
sure that you keep your protein intake
at a moderate amount not too much not
too low and so the amino acid that helps
increase growth hormone is arginine and
arginine is in a lot of different
proteins because arginine is an amino
acid and so you want to consume protein
that's not missing
arginine okay so that has a complete
profile of amino acids
and so eggs are really good nuts have
arginine any animal meats have arginine
seafood has arginine all these will help
with growth hormone other ways to
increase growth hormone would be
high intensity exercise of a short
duration as in high intensity interval
training also sleep enhances growth
hormone so you need that recovery after
the exercise and of course if you want
to shut down carbohydrate to keep your
blood sugars very very high as in being
a diabetic all right next one is
testosterone that is increased with zinc
and now we're getting into the red meats
we're getting into seafood especially
oysters
oysters have the most zinc out of
anything you can eat so oysters and red
meat and also you want to avoid estrogen
okay so you probably want to avoid dairy
and anything else that's estrogenic like
fermented soy and don't go on a low-fat
diet you want to provide enough fat for
the body because testosterone is a
steroid hormone that is built from
cholesterol that goes the same for
cortisol and estrogen and even
progesterone all those are sex hormones
that need cholesterol as they're
building a block now if you're female
and you have too much
androgen which is a form of testosterone
and i'm talking about a condition called
pcos
polycystic ovarian syndrome and where
the androgens are just too high how do
you lower that well you lower the
hormone that's triggering that whole
mechanism which is
insulin okay so you go in low carb you
do fasting that will help you
lower the output of androgens from your
ovaries okay next hormone is estrogen
this is a big one a lot of both men and
women are estrogen dominant because of
our environment we're exposed to now
plastics okay where an average person in
a week consumes the amount of plastic
that would be the same as eating a
credit card okay all those plastics are
estrogenic they're endocrine disruptors
okay and i'm talking about the plastics
in the drinking water so you'd want to
get a filter
for your drinking water don't drink the
tap water but to help regulate estrogen
because there's three different
estrogens and to help regulate and i
mean lowering the bad one and increasing
the good one
cruciferous vegetables are the best the
kale the broccoli the brussels sprouts
the cabbage the arugula
awesome radishes and you can also
regulate estrogen by consuming sea kelp
because iodine helps to curb the excess
amount of estrogen and one additional
thing is to avoid dairy because there
are certain hormones in dairy
that can actually make you more
astrogenic and then if you have low
estrogen if you wanted to increase it
fermented soy organic fermented soy
would probably help you like miso soup
tofu
things like that now progesterone okay
is enhanced with omega-3 fatty acids so
that would be like
salmon that would be like cod liver oil
and then we get to another hormone
called vitamin d yes that's right
vitamin d is a hormone it's not really a
vitamin and so the way to increase
vitamin d is through the sun but also
you can get some not all of it if you
consume cod liver oil fatty fish like
salmon and then we get to the big
hormone that's pretty much destroying
everything and that's insulin okay too
much insulin can be lowered if you
reduce your carbs if you do intermittent
fasting if you avoid msg but here's the
problem with insulin if you don't have
enough okay
like in a diabetes type one
the thing to do is not to increase it
with eating more sugar because that's
just gonna that's not gonna help you
it's better to do this support the gland
that makes insulin with just general
healthy foods so there are certain
things that can increase your hormones
to help balance them but in reality it's
better to support the endocrine system
as a whole
with
two things
healthy keto
and intermittent fasting and for that
information you need to watch this video
right here check it out